hello Steve you have a nice coffee
you're very excited about I'm very
excited the rills just woken up oh yeah
this is gonna be the best interview now
so you were fantastic and welcome
tomorrow in also fantastic advice both
very serious films any time I think of
you in a movie I think it's gonna be
hysterically funny but both films were
very meaningful what made you want to
take on
welcome tomorrow when I saw the
documentary Marvin call and I just fell
in love with it
I loved what it had to say about
humanity and kindness and and hatred and
resilience and just it touched me and I
the character of Mark Hogan camp who I
now have gotten to know and become
friends with moved me and inspired me
that's why I wanted to be a part of it
yeah
is it a challenge to play a role about
someone's life for sure yeah I think
there's an added sense of responsibility
you want it to you it's never gonna be
perfect but you want it to be as right
as you can make it yeah and especially
somebody like Mark who is just the
kindest person and I it means a lot to
me too
to try to get it right on his behalf so
you've had a lot of dolls and action
figures made of you so far did ya
anchorman yeah yeah the office mm-hmm
grew what good while and we do you have
a favorite doll and what's like going on
in your life do I have a favorite doll
that's a question I never thought I'd be
asked at a press junket you know what I
the welcome our own thing I think only
ego wise I like it because it is like
the way better-looking version of me no
yeah no it's true and it's it's kind of
cool like you look at yourself I think
hmm what if yeah
maybe $100,000 that's surgery I'd be
right there but I think maybe maybe that
just just
purely when I think of you and Leslie
Mann in a movie I think of course four
year old virgin hysterically funny what
would you say is the biggest difference
working with Leslie from then till now
um well she hasn't changed a bit she she
looks exactly the same and I think that
was I don't even know fifteen years ago
yeah she's just you know what it's it's
like picking up with an old friend it
when when time passes but it doesn't
seem like any time has passed that that
was exactly what it's like she's and and
I I loved her work in this movie and and
I root as we were shooting it I remember
talking her about insane what you're
doing is so specific and so and so so
tricky in a lot of ways that you
wouldn't necessarily think on the
surface of what she's doing character
wise but I just love her I think
obviously she's a really great comedic
actress but she's she's such a great
dramatic actress as well yeah and I know
that the office cast tweeted like a
reunion picture I know I wish I could
have made it can you do like a holiday
party like how often can you see them i
boy I mean I haven't seen everybody
together you know I mean I see people
from time to time here and there but I'm
we're all planning to have like and
we'll probably have to plan it like a
year in advance something everybody can
clear their schedule we get together and
have a big blowout that's that's
definitely in the offing yeah I hope you
tweet it because we love it of course
you